all right cool thanks everyone for
showing up today I appreciate you coming
out and hearing about voice to reiterate
my name is Michael Henry I work for
Mozilla I'm originally a web engineer
these days I work on a team called open
innovation and I'll talk a little bit
about that in a second and the project
I'm working on is called common voice
common voices Mozilla's initiative to
crowdsource a large data set of voices
to be used in speech technology we're
trying to solve the data problem for
machine learning and voice we're
currently working on multiple languages
meaning languages other than English so
if you're interested in collecting
language for or collecting speech data
for your language reach out to me I have
some contact info there let's see next
so today we're going to talk about a
little bit about voice HTML about the
difference between a wet the web and app
stores we're gonna do a brief history of
the web then I'm going to get into my
voice HTML proposal like I promised and
I'll do a case study on booking a flight
with voice HTML then we'll try to get
into some Q&A if we have time for that
okay so disclaimers I hate doing
disclaimers but I'm going to need to
this time the if you read the pitch the
pitch that I gave you is more of
clickbait to try to get people here who
are interested in voice and interested
in the Internet I made some bold
statements there that I'm going to
propose a new protocol and do a case
study on that protocol it's not going to
be the protocol you you might think I'm
not this is not a technical talk I'm not
gonna release a library or in our API
there's going to be more about trust and
so I hope you'll bear with me as we talk
about this today because this is not
this is maybe a little different than
what you're expecting but I hope it'll
be good ok voice HTML so around the end
of 2016 I had just finished my last very
successful project at Mozilla called
Firefox OS you might have heard of it it
was so I moved over to the open
innovation team and what I was doing was
trying to what open innovation team
is we reach out to other teams within
Mozilla and try to get them to be more
successful by embracing open practices
specifically what I was doing in 2016
was working on a project called Dino
tank and Dino tank is Mozilla's internal
kind of ideas contest anybody including
staff volunteers pretty much anybody who
is interested in Dino tank can submit
ideas to dino tank and then we have a
team of executives who you would pitch
to if we like your idea and then the top
ideas get selected to be worked on and
for working on that we would do a week
of a Design Thinking design sprint and
we'd have about eight different people
from all sorts of different walks of
life and skill sets and we just see we'd
investigate the problem and see if we
can build anything they're one of those
ideas was querying the voice-enabled
internet how can the internet and voice
work together in the future because they
don't play together very nicely right
now and then one of the concepts that
came out of the design sprint you can
see it over here a little bit is voice
HTML and what that text says it says
voice analogy of HTML allows simple
authoring of apps that can understand
speech and speak everyone loved this
idea you can see it had by far the most
votes those little blue dots are votes
in the Design Thinking practice and so
we really wanted to explore this and so
what I'd like to do is kind of explore
the topic of voice HTML by exploring
what the web is and so we're gonna go
we're gonna do like a brief history here
ok so let's start with the web why do we
like it why is it so great I mean why
why would anybody want to use the web
over competing models which we'll talk
about in a second as a developer you're
the apps you make are easy they're easy
to make they're cross-platform you don't
have to worry about gatekeepers there's
no revenue sharing model there's no
approval process and as a user we love
we love the web that's what we use on
desktop your computers are now basically
browsers with a couple of other apps and
the reason we like it is workflow we
have multiple tabs open we have our
email maybe our calendar we could have
like you're looking up
concert tickets while Wikipedian things
it's it's very seamless and quick to
kind of discover information and get
things done transact we love that we
also love that we don't have to install
and these last two points are really
important we're going to talk about them
today and in fact focus on them there's
there is already an established trust
model for the internet we know how to
trust it we put our credit card
information in there we'll put all
social security tax ID in there so we
trust it when and it's taken us a while
to get there and I'd like to explore
that a little bit and then also we have
choice there's a ton of choice on the
internet I can choose the device that
I'm using I can use a desktop I can use
a phone I can use any number of IOT
devices you can choose what browser you
can choose what sites you're using these
choices is really paramount to what the
web is okay but the web is not the only
model that's extremely successful right
now there are other models out there and
I think we need to examine a little bit
because with all these great things why
would anyone choose anything different
well let's look at it app stores that's
the other big model right
I mean app stores love it or hate it
they're extremely successful and they're
actually pretty nice so let's talk about
why they're nice as a developer you're
the SDK and API moves very fast
why because there's no consensus needed
a single group of people can decide and
then everyone else follows suit and a
lot of times this is actually really
good as a developer because you get
things move very quickly I don't know if
any of you are iOS iOS developers but
you get a lot of updates and always very
exciting next is you have a direct
channel to your users you know exactly
where they are because there's only one
place they can be it's not like the web
and then performance of course you know
you can optimize specifically for your
platform much easier than this kind of
cross-platform world that we love about
the web as a user now why the users like
App Store's well there's an easy trust
model I can trust that App Store and
everything that comes out of that App
Store I can trust
I haven't never the other day I had to I
tried to make a meme picture that I sent
to my family and I'd never done it
before so I just went and downloaded
five
apps from the App Store I didn't care
about I didn't worry about it I just did
it and whether or not that's a good
thing
it is really nice as user to not have to
think about what I'm visiting and what
I'm doing also the content is curated
and tailored for me and then also for
the story I generally like kind of the
stuff that comes up the stuff that's
surfaced at the top of the App Store of
app stores and then of course
performance I love performance you know
the web is great it's moving along but
it doesn't hold a candle to a native app
if you're making a video game which I
used to do a former life you wouldn't
you wouldn't do the web but
unfortunately you wouldn't use html5 you
can but you're already having a
difficult time just getting to the same
level of performance as an app as an app
is by default now there's also with app
stores there's this third value pool
that we need to talk about it's the
owner of that place there is no owner of
the web there is owners of webs of app
stores and of course they love it
because they get 30% that's our standard
cut also they they get to control the
experience for their users they need to
show exactly what they see and they can
limit competition if you if you compete
with a business model of someone who
owns an app store they're not gonna let
you into that App Store this is really
important okay
so we've talked a little bit about the
difference between web and app stores
let's talk about where this kind of
competition came from and so we're gonna
we're gonna take a little journey back
in time we'll start with 2007 Steve Jobs
let me just say it we want native
third-party applications on iphone you
know you might not remember but before
this time before he said this the web
was dominant on mobile even on iPhone
iPhone existed before the App Store and
there was a lot of reasons why the web
was really a great killer app for phones
especially because of Steve Jobs
actually he he added a lot of these
features you see here GPS and maps he
did that actually well he did it he made
it really really good you can make phone
calls if you see it you know a phone
number you can make phone call you can
add things to your homescreen basically
like bookmarking to your home screen
that was that was a new concept and then
this
pinch-to-zoom double tap it was a way of
using desktop web pages on your phone
see at the time there are other phones
that were smartphones and that had the
web but they weren't they weren't a
great experience and so in the early
days Steve Jobs was really bullish about
the mobile web when he released the
iPhone he said this
what's the developer story you got the
web baby we got we got Safari it's the
best mobile browser out there and he had
a reason to be optimistic it had great
and great SDK and tooling already you
already had documentation you already
had this vast distribution platform you
already had content discovery figured
out right so it's a no-brainer and then
he beat all of the the existing browsers
that were out there I mean look at the
BlackBerry versus his phone this is
similar time you know he had touch
versus versus scroll wheel like double
touch bigger screens and incredible
performance so for a while the web was a
big killer app on the phones like how
long was that well let's look June 2007
he said 2.0 applications and then
October 2007 native app store so that's
about three months where the web was
amazing on phones but it was a great
time but however the iPhone was not the
first smartphone there were other phones
that were around before the iPhone and
the web was actually a killer app you
had all the world's knowledge in your
pocket you had transactions you had vast
communities discussing various niche
topics so you had to have it on your
phone why was it in a killer app so
let's look at that you have to go back
to 1995 this is the boom of the Internet
this is where everything happened one
year it's amazing
we had Java JavaScript Ruby PHP all
released 1.0 that year Internet Explorer
opera Amazon Yahoo eBay Craigslist these
all came from 1995 first wiki the
wikiwikiweb came out in 1995 front page
a first WYSIWYG editor for HTML as far
as I know anyway and then the first
computer wiretap that's pretty important
and you can see that phones they were
very rudimentary at this time but they
had the way
you can see over here there's this Nokia
it's actually the first phone that had
internet capabilities on it had email
check it had map functionality
it was a huge boon for phones and why
why is this good
well the web had trust figured out I
would put my credit card into the web at
this time I'd make payments Amazon was
around right or Amazon at least became
around because of that and and then the
other thing is discovery discovery is
really important and difficult concept
when you when you're trying to make a
distribution platform the web did it
really well so let's say that I wanted
to look up my favorite movie you've got
mail how would I do that I would search
it right I'd search for it if we're
gonna talk about like search and where
search came from there's really only one
company we ever need to talk about right
Infoseek the year before the Internet
boom infancy came around and
revolutionized search they were the
first to do real-time updates so as you
added content to the web so with their
search index update they also did cost
per click ads this changed the game and
behavioural targeting this also changed
the game and they also did pop-ups
unfortunately Google came around about
three years later and just crushed them
for a number of reasons we're not going
to talk about it or I don't even know
all those reasons but this had a lasting
effect on the Internet
later this site would kind of break up
and become go.com and then also Baidu
was spawned out of this out of this
knowledge so this had a huge effect on
the Internet but search so we're talking
about search now what did people do
before search right like how did they
find content
let's look it's stuff like this
directories and portals these all these
links grouped together this was kind of
the original vision of the Internet is
this linked document content and it was
great because you could find things you
were looking for and you had kind of a
quick search type thing but not this is
not the search that we know it today you
literally crawled the internet to find
what you were looking for but people
loved it although at the time nobody
would put their credit card into this
so the trust trusting of the internet
didn't come overnight right
so is this little thing here is this the
killer app for phones in 1992 when this
was around no phones were the killer of
the internet back then you picked this
thing up and it would just kill whatever
you were downloading at that time so
phones in the internet they didn't play
together in the early days I think a lot
of that had to do with the trust
there wasn't any trust established with
how you know you might transact on the
Internet it was just a shared document
store but but why is that important like
why is a shared document story even
anything we're talking about let's go
back one more step the last step this is
Tim berners-lee this was in his
executive summary of the world wide web
and he said this project was started
with a philosophy that much academic
information should be freely available
to anyone no matter where they are in
the world so this is the idea he wasn't
thinking about payments he wasn't
thinking about discovery he was thinking
that information should be spread to
everyone and so I think that if we think
if we talk about what we like about the
internet and how voice should work on
the Internet
I really like this as a kind of
visionary piece okay so now we've taken
kind of a brief history of the internet
just random one actually and I'm
supposed to propose a new protocol of
voice right that's what I that's what I
came here to do I'd like to do that I'm
going to do that but I need a moment to
talk about something first
and that's trust so if you'll just trust
me for a minute we're gonna do some
pictures and we're going to talk about
how Trust works on the internet or with
technology in general so let's start
with Tim berners-lee 1991 no internet in
the early days this was this might have
been the computer that that TBL himself
was using right it was very simple for
us to understand and very easy for us to
trust so you see this briefcase here
with money this is a metaphor and what
it relates to is personal data and I'd
like to put money inside a personal data
because I
they're intrinsically linked but money
isn't the only reason why you should
protect your personal data there are
also things like manipulation that we
could talk about but let's just say that
money is the let's just start with money
you have money you want to protect it in
this briefcase so you need to put it
somewhere safe now you can see there's
this like blue hazy cloud around the
briefcase that blue hazy cloud that
represents trust because any time you
have money you're gonna need to trust
where it is right so we're gonna we're
gonna use that blue cloud to kind of
talk about how these different models
work all right so we have this computer
it was great you had your spreadsheet
you had your tax information you had
maybe finance and bank bank records and
games but you know where would you get
those games how would you install an app
in this time let's do another diagram so
this is how we would do it you would
physically get in your car probably with
your family you go to a store
brick-and-mortar app store and you would
purchase it and you'd be very happy and
you'd come home come home and you'll
notice that there is a trust cloud
around the store well that's that's
pretty important here because the
software you buy from them you better
trust it right because you're about to
install it on your computer
however the nice thing was and the
reason why we trusted is because we knew
how stores worked we understood that
trust model plus we also got our
computer and our software from the same
place we also got a computer fixed from
the same place there's a little bit of
conflict of interest there but we would
trust that right we would we would we
thought they were experts and all the
software that they surfaced we just
assumed that that's what the software
that's out there right like that's
software you get we didn't think there's
stuff outside of this this is this was
very easy for us to understand you'll
also notice that and I think this is
something that's pretty important is for
both of these trust clouds you also have
a choice you can choose to go to my
Crescenta or some other store you can
choose to use IBM or Apple or any number
of Microsoft any number of computers
back in the day so you had choice and
without this choice there's really not
trust the trust is an active thing at
least to me if you if you talk about
what trust is without choice it's more
like hope right because you don't have a
choice
trust as you're choosing the truth
you're choosing to trust the things that
you choose okay well I just want to I
love this picture because it it really
uh it's like the feeling I had whenever
I'd go to Microsoft you know I couldn't
or whenever I go to my Crescenta I
couldn't install from an app store back
in the day but when I would go here I
knew some cool stuff was happening so
let's talk about the trust model for the
internet this is much more complex right
this is what Tim berners-lee had in mind
you notice the first thing that I want
to talk about it's on the left here is a
it's I'm calling it the user agent into
your browser there's this whole new
trust model I had to form around the
browser this is kind of like your
gatekeeper to the Internet right it's
what all the information flows through
and it's separate from the content it's
not all grouped together like this we
had to learn about what a browser is we
had to learn how to trust our browsers
and then on the other side of this you
have a bunch of websites which are all
constantly under construction and
constantly changing where do you search
to find them and we had to learn to
trust each of these individually or not
trust them we understand this now right
this is ten years later 15 years later
30 years later we understand we also
have this middle part which we're not
going to talk about but it's pretty
interesting you have like these dump
trucks of information right and that's
the information superhighway and in the
middle is all this magic in this magic
there is some complexity there there is
trust there is a lot of things to
discuss
you have the ICANN in there you have
backbones of ISPs you have government
regulation but for the normal everyday
use of installing or using content you
don't think about that right it's all
kind of hidden for you your user agent
brokers all that yeah this is a really
cool this is a really cool break down
because you get trusts so many granular
choices of trust and then this user
agent over here it doesn't care what
content you see you just want to make
sure that when you see that content that
you have a good experience while doing
it so this is a disinterested third
party in what you're doing what you're
using this platform for this is pretty
important to how Trust works on the
Internet let's go to the App Store model
so here's here's the Apple App Store
and despite the fact that we put this in
jail so it looks you know we're trying
to lead a little bit users actually love
this model because you have a single
source of trust you just you just use
this software use this phone use this
app store and everything is just kind of
taken care of for you all right
of course they're bad parts about being
locked in the platform the developers
there you have to register you have to
make sure that you're part of this
ecosystem but users love this and so
this is a very popular successful model
but it's not the way things have to work
okay I promised to talk about voice
didn't I
let's talk about voice so we don't
really have established trust models
around voice yet we need to we're
starting to kind of formulate one and
it's looking a lot more like the app
store model and it's looking like the
Internet and it's because it's much
easier to just trust the product you buy
into your house but look at all these
new data types like you have your speech
you have the type of music you listen to
you have control over your house and
data about your house your locks your
lights your habits you have your ambient
noise all sorts of stuff here that
there's really a little bit scary and
but we you know you have to choose to
trust all of it or nothing right that's
that's where it is right now and then
that's kind of just the tip of the
iceberg there's all these processes that
go on underneath from the people on
these platforms that we don't know about
right and I am a big fan of Google
Amazon Apple I use their products all
the time but it's always good to be a
little bit skeptical about what we're
using and try to understand how could
this data be used how might they be
using this data okay so
I promised to propose a new API for the
web but you've probably seen by now that
we've talked mostly about trust more
than the web it's there more than any
sort of technology technology we're
gonna continue that but I am going to
propose a new protocol might not be what
you think ok so voice HTML I said in my
pitch a new protocol for how voice
assistance can interact with web sites
right so I better propose this right but
anytime you introduce a new protocol on
the Internet if you can't do it really
fast right I could go and have the best
protocol right now but if there's no
consensus around it
nobody's gonna use it so you have to
have break it down into phases I've
broken it down into four phases for you
so just bear with me as we go through
this phase one international
screenreader day what if for once a year
all you could use the internet was using
a screen reader right we could get the
best we could get all of the top
browsers to come together and decide ok
on a certain day you can't use the
internet except through a screen reader
yeah I think is ok but we're gonna do it
are you a browser vendor but so there's
a couple reasons why we want to do this
and I'm actually not a browser vendor I
don't represent most of us so I hope to
not I mean I do represent them but I
don't talk about Firefox I talk about
voice so I can't do this myself we have
to do this together
but the benefits here are more than just
getting voice to be better on the
internet we'll have more empathy from
users and developers right people will
understand what it's like to use the web
without these great kind of cool
interactive experiences that are visual
interactive experiences and then
immediately you'll have better
accessibility like what if we chose
black friday to have international
screenreader day right you're gonna have
people are gonna make their sites super
accessible overnight so let's do it any
of you our browser vendors come talk to
me step2 souped-up screen readers so
naturally we're not going to be under
we're not going to be able to take it
right it's gonna be too difficult for us
most of us
and so we're gonna have to add some
functionality to the screen readers for
this one day to make sure we can use the
internet it's like before and still be
at least somewhat productive so where to
start there
well we surveyed Amazon echo Alexa users
and Google home users and we asked them
what are the features of your product
that you would really like to use and so
I think that would be a great place to
start for screen readers if you could do
email better if you could discover new
features and skills if you could read
and summarize news and order food like
these are you know the Internet already
can do a lot of this stuff right so we
just have to make screeners have a
better experience what screen readers
need to do this is it needs to be able
to track a little bit of state about you
and it needs to be extensible and then
we could rely on everyone to extend
expend to build a really great
experience in an open way right okay
step 3
Robbie the reader so Robbie is your
friend Robbie knows everything about you
he knows that you like using go euro for
train trips he knows that you are
tracking an Olympic figure skating he
lives in and with your computer your
phone your speakers and he's always
there for you he's like your Mission
Control or your person in a chair who's
always by the internet for you
he's like a copilot in life who can use
the Internet you know and there are a
couple of things here that are
aspirational like a conversational
interface some sort of roaming profile
that has your data that you can still
trust a semantic understanding of the
web and and know a knowledge of how to
use websites right so this is this is
interesting like instead of an API that
Robbie is interacting with browser is
the API he's using the browser for you
and most importantly he has your trust
because without trust you're not going
to be able to do any of the transacting
that you would want to on the internet
with Robbie need that trust right okay
final step disappointment
so this is not going to work for a
number of reasons right like screen
readers they're for reading screens
they're not for adding some sort of like
personal voice assistant natural
language understanding conversational
interfaces they're still very very hard
right we're getting there
but it's years out speech the text
text-to-speech those are still hard
that's why you only have a couple of
players in this space semantic
understanding of the web people you know
this is moving really fast in academia
but we're still far away and we didn't
even talk about monetization that's
right so it's gonna be hard to do Robbie
Robbie the reader but the point of this
is that we don't actually need any new
protocols for the web web has some great
api's already you have aria and the
accessibility tree that would be great
for semantic understanding we have the
web speech API with speech synthesis so
you can understand your voice and talk
back to you sites can do this today we
have real-time communication channels
like WebSockets and you have Java
scripts tying it all together right so
we really have the platform we need we
have so many things figured out so let's
go back to our model of the Internet
so we had this took us years and years
before we trusted this but we learned to
like this because we learned about
choice right and this is this is still
prevailing model despite the success of
app source so can we bring a similar
model to the Internet and the biggest
change here is you see just on the Left
we have a house instead of your computer
so there's a little bit more types of
data that are stored inside there right
and then you have this little speaker
which is a user agent for you so right
now they're not user agents they're
vendor agents you buy product to voice
product as a representative of that
company but your browser it actually
represents you supposed to be completely
independent of the content that you get
from it and so we need this sort of
trust model in voice so the protocol
that I'm proposing here is not about
technology it's about how we understand
our products and how
user products and really what I'm doing
here today is I want to propose a
question or a problem and I want your
help on it that's why I did this
clickbait kind of title is because I
wanted people who are architects of the
Internet to talk to us about it because
we don't we don't know the answer to
this and we're trying we're trying to
work that out right now okay so the last
thing that I had promised to do was
compare screen readers versus voice HTML
and booking a flight well you know now
that voice HTML that's a vapor where
it's not there's nothing there's no
libraries or any sort of thing to
compare with so no matter how difficult
it is to book a flight with a screen
reader and trust me it is very difficult
it beats voice HTML because it works
today right so this is working but I
thought it might be interesting to
instead compare what we have today
versus what it was like before the
internet how did how did we book flights
before the internet Wow right I didn't
know I had to ask I had to ask somebody
I asked my dad dad said well I call a
travel agent and he was paid by the
hotel or airline as a percentage of
costs so that's a conflict of interest
right so he would go shop around and he
would look for travel agents that felt
trustworthy in general I wasn't even
asking about trust he brought up trust
himself so Trust is always embedded in
the things we do and you notice here
that there's something interesting this
built-in conflict of interest these
travel agents they didn't represent him
they represented the airline or hotel
this was a vendor agent all right and so
we have mechanisms in place where we can
beat that model I think ok
so that's what I wanted to propose today
is how do we understand the products
that we use and how do we learn to trust
them and how can we make a better future
for how we might interact with these
products in the future so final thoughts
Trust is hard right but it's important
it's what made the web successful it's
what made App Store successful what
makes technology successful the web
I don't think needs any new api's for
voice not yet maybe it will as we go
along maybe we could extend Aria in ways
I can add some interesting interaction
stuff maybe we can add some new API s
for maybe Open Graph meta tags to
announce that this is a voice enabled
site and you can find it on search
engines we can talk about that but I
don't think that's the most pressing
topic right now what we need what voice
needs is a new trust model that's like
the web we need that user agent so to
wrap up my question to you and what I
would love help with is how how are we
going to do this how are we going to
change our models for how we interact
with these voice products right where
the we are the architects of the
internet we kind of move the direction
we have a lot of power and how this
thing's work so how can we do it I
really don't know if you have thoughts
and ideas about any of this
trust reach out to me this is my contact
information also voice damos load org
this is our common voice project so you
can go and donate your voice right now
this will be a public data set Creative
Commons level zero completely public
domain we make that promise to you so
everything you do is benefiting the
public good so come check out our
website and also our team the open
innovation team we have a blog medium
blog we have we talk about diversity
inclusion we talk about open practices
talk about voice so all of those things
are there but thank you that was
you